it's fascinating to think that koi19 is
uh as a result of a virus evolving
together with like twitter
yeah like figuring out how we can sneak
past the defenses of the humans
so it's not bad enough and then the
misinformation all that kind of stuff
together is operating in such a way that
the virus can spread
effectively i wonder i mean obviously
a virus is not intelligent but there's a
uh there's a rhyme and a rhythm
to the way this whole evolutionary
process works and creates these
fascinating things that spread
throughout the entire civilization
absolutely it's um
yeah i i'm i'm completely fascinated by
this
idea of uh social media in particular
how it replicates how it grows you know
i've been
how it inner how it actually starts
interacting with the biology
of the virus masks who's going to get
vaccinated
politics like these seem so external to
virus biology
but it's become so in intertwined and uh
and it's it's interesting and i actually
think we could find out that you know
the virus actually
becomes uh obviously not
uh intentionally but
you know we could find that choosing
people choosing not to wear masks
usually choosing not to counter this
virus
in a regimented and sort of organized
way
effectively gives the virus more
opportunity to escape
you